We're back here-
Yeah!
With Zach Braff.
I never thought you'd do it.
Oh.
Oh, absolutely, and I put my signature flower on there too
just to make it my own.
It gives it such a lovely kick.
I love it.
Thank you so much.
It's so amazing.
Oh, I'm so glad you guys sent it to me.
Drew, you got to come on the podcast.
I would love, I'd be honored to come
on your very big hit podcast.
Obviously, we're with Zach Braff and Donald Faison,
and we're about to surprise a Scrubs fan
who credits the show with helping her
become the doctor that she is today,
and she actually thinks that she's here to talk about
the shows that inspired them to get into medicine.
But Zach and Donald, if it's okay, we're gonna hide you.
Okay.
All right, you guys hide, shh.
And then we're gonna bring in Dr. Jean Robey.
Okay, here we go.
We'll see you in one second.
All right.
I'm gonna tell her I'm an uber fan.
All right, please welcome Dr. Jean Robey.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
Hi.
Hi, Dr. Jean Robey.
It's so nice to meet you.
Oh, that's so great.
I feel like I'm in the room with a giant.
Do you mean the giants on my onesie?
(Jean laughing)
It's Donald-
= You really got dressed up.
I did.
Well, I heard that you were a huge Scrubs fan,
and that influenced your life, and I'm a giant Scrubs fan,
and I'm like, just crazy for the show.
So I thought I wanted to ask you
like how the show has had the biggest impact
on your life as a doctor?
I swear that show mattered more than anything
I could think back of during training.
JD's internal dialogue, Turk's slickness,
Elliot's neuroticism, Laverne's moral compass,
Dr. Cox's hard truths, even Kelso.
I love them all, and I'm literally the doctor I am today
with all my wackiness and big heart because of Scrubs.
Oh, Dr. Jean, I love that so much.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I got to page somebody.
We're paging doctors JD and Turk, JD and Turk.
(audience clapping)
Are you there?
Well, hello, Jean.
Oh my God.
Hey.
Oh my God, oh my God!
Hi, Jean!
Oh my God.
Can I?
Am I in the show with them?
Oh my God.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Hi, Jean.
Go like this.
Oh, that's so-
Group hug starting with me,
group hug starting with me, let's go.
Group hug, Jean.
Oh my God, wait til my kids see this!
Group hug, Jean!
Oh this is amazing.
Jean, not even hugging us.
Give him a hug, Jean.
Oh, yes, yes.
Give him a hug, here we go.
Okay, and big kisses.
Thank you so much.
Big kisses.
Oh, yeah, oh my God, my bad, Jean.
This way, no, this way.
Oh, this way, like this?
Where are you?
Where?
This is not right?
Here we go.
Oh my God.
I love this so much.
By the way-
Oh, it should have been in studio.
I also think-
(Zach laughing)
By the way, maybe when this is all safe,
and you're gonna actually be the one to tell us, Dr. Robey,
when that is, we could all have a hangout.
Yes.
And we could all wear these pajamas together.
Oh, that would be so worth it.
And have a pajama party.
Totally worth it.
Jean, Jean.
Oh my gosh.
Dr. Jean, thank you for-
This is amazing.
I can't stand it.
Thank you so much for what you said, by the way,
I can't tell you how much that means to Donald and I,
it really brings a giant smile to our faces and our hearts.
(audience cheering)
What kind of medicine did you wind up going into?
I actually left surgery, Turk,
and went to medicine the very year
JD started his internship.
I'm so sorry, Turk, I left surgery because of JD.
Wait, let me get this straight,
you think my name is Turk?
Yeah, Turk Turkison.
Well, I mean, it is, right?
You think my name is Turk?
'Cause that's the only person I wanna know.
Don't break the-
Donald, don't break the mystery for her.
You know what?
I'm not gonna kill the fantasy, you got it.
Yeah, don't break any mystery for her.
Oh, I mean, this is my fantasy, right?
Like I mean, I got Drew and I got you guys.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know
what else, I'm like Elliot, I'm Elliot.
Yeah.
Okay.
There it is.
By the way, Zach and Donald have actually talked about
the fact that the iHeartRadio people,
in lieu of the success of this podcast,
Fake Doctors Real Friends, are talking about going on tour.
So maybe you and I can go and meet them and like see a show?
Yeah.
I can't stop.
My whole life is going to be structured around
these two guys and you and reminiscing Scrubs.
It's been the only levity during the pandemic.
It has literally gotten me through wearing three masks
and dealing with life and death.
I can't stand it.
Well, you're a hero.
Do you know that, right?
Thank you so much.
You are a hero, and it's very sweet
that you're saying such nice things to us,
but I think I can say, on behalf of all three of us,
we want to bow down to you and thank you,
and all the frontline workers
(audience cheering)
for all the insane danger you're putting yourselves in,
and how you're doing this, you're the superheroes.
You're the super heroes.
Well, all of us really kept it together
because we could laugh at ourselves
and we could have something to laugh about.
So honestly, you guys are artists,
and really we owe a lot of how do we get up everyday
and do it all over again to your artistry.
So thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much,
and Dr. Robey, I'm going to get you this swag,
clearly-
Yes!
And so we can wear it together,
and then maybe we can be in the front row of the live show.
Like a couple of crazies.
(all laughing)
I just love you dancing in it.
Look at it, go, Drew!
Go Drew, go Drew!
(Drew laughing)
I never imagined you were gonna wear the onesie.
I'm so happy right now that you're dancing around
in that onesie.
Oh my God.
It's such a pleasure.
By the way, super comfortable, Dr. Jean.
I think you're gonna to be really happy with this.
(all laughing)
Yes!
I'm wearing 'em.
I'm wearing the scrubs.
Oh yeah, exactly.
And we're going to be wearing onesies,
and we're gonna come to your live show.
Zach, Donald, Dr. Robey.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
(upbeat music)